hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
Friday the 13th received an update today
which I have been waiting for for almost
a year now it introduced the
single-player campaign mode in short
there are 10 scenarios to progress
through in which we play as the
homicidal maniac himself Jason I thought
this could be a great bonding experience
between us as we decimate every living
thing in sight anyway if you are ready
let's do this
bring on the gorge it might be faster if
you helped man
man just hurry up I want to miss the hot
chicks the party
it has voice-acting bloody brilliant I'm
already hooked I'm already hooked
alright what we doing what we're doing
make them remember what they did to us
Jason
kill them oh mama I've missed your voice
Pamela Voorhees we will do as you say so
it looks like we've got two of these
tick out so we will first grab every
sharp instrument we can find just in
case we need to impale them at some
point and wait what's this oh we can
stalk like a filthy old man I'm not sure
how I feel about that one's going for a
pee by the looks of it and the other one
is under the bonnet or the hood of the
car we'll come back to him we will come
back him in a little bit
and we'll trying to smash his head off
with the car but in the meantime let's
follow this chap he doesn't realise that
I'm quite heavy footed I'm really heavy
footed come on you must have noticed
that dude right
he's got his spam dagger out now is the
time to introduce ourselves
now that's how you make a first
impression
yes come on with some morally cinematic
kills yeah heal for mother hopefully he
will venture back Ruggeri girls he'll
venture background and we can try and
trap him in the hood of the car don't
notice don't know just me do you think
running do you think he'll noticed as if
we run oh well if we quicken up we can
grab him anyway okay so no survivors
successful undetected successful and xB
score successful so we did everything
Jason one lakh mother is talking to you
find them do we finish Pamela or Lux we
have the hariya mode what was the one
before that
oh the cabin buggy alright this is
pretty cool all the things we could have
done those things will kill you grab and
kill bug see on a smoke break but I just
fixed it smash the car as it tries to
escape oh that's a good that's good and
helpful mechanic get all three skulls
with part 5 Jason this is so cool let's
move on to number 2 let's not look at
the objectives it's more fun just going
for it
[Music]
whoa did you just hear that sounded like
screaming
getting bombed upstairs man so quality
life just gonna have to keep trying babe
yes what's going on are you doing just
testing it out honey
[Music]
not the [ __ ] electrician here don't
be scared
I wasn't expecting so much sexy talk
oh well Jason will put an end to
whatever mischief they're up to make
them remember Jason make them suffer
mama has spoken so once going out to the
song electric power unit so I presume we
can electrocute him and the other one
she was cooking to think we kids maybe
get into the kitchen without her
noticing well try so he oh he's already
outside oh so the electric shock so your
lectricity Shack is just there okay
let's let's try the front door let's
just go for it
straighten the front door if she's
around the back in the kitchen we should
be able to walk in here without anyone
noticing at all famous last words
this is so done um in fact if you're
watching a mole bile it may be worth
changing your brightness open your
brightness you should be able to see a
little bit more I'll try on some
contrast too there she is the woman of
the hour cooking away and here we go
another cinematic kill enjoy
[Music]
wow this is looking really good have
they improved the graphics there's some
sort of engine update must have taken
place because it did not look this good
a year ago anyway where is he come on
Mitch where are you where there we go
we're coming for you Mitch son of a
[ __ ] I can handle the dark
no biggie not afraid anything he's
everyone deaf in this game these
footsteps are so loud oh well let's not
question it nice to meet you Mitch
[Applause]
come on Jason the most electrifying man
in sports horror entertainment sorry I
don't get um what y'all look at new
people I'm like a giddy child in a
murder Shop of Horrors hello my own
about I'm sorry this is why I don't live
stream because gibberish falls out of my
mouth and I just don't know what I'm
gonna say next
Oh stock you in no like Oh God like that
that's why I don't live stream anyways
we still have two more people to find it
looked like Chad was one of them and was
the other one Jerri yeah
Jenni and me if you've seen commando
you'll understand that reference come on
jenni
there they are just about see them on
the right side
dami they walk slower than I expected um
I think I'll speed this up in the Edit
oh let's watch them through the stock
you window no one will ever notice us
here she should the darling anyone here
AJ I'm gonna check the house see what's
up right so here's the plan once he
comes over here will quickly sneak round
and we'll try and throttle him and throw
him on the open fire your demise is
coming Chad prepare yourself to be
wrecked Oh it'd be no a star for God's
sake alright it's okay it's okay we will
go there he'll do you catch him up oh
let's just take out Jenny instead Jenny
because he has escaped
you must feel my wrath
[Music]
oh good so good I love the kills in this
game
the brilliant alright we failed with
bales but we did ok no survivors failed
undetected failed point score success oh
we did get enough points so oh well
every cloud has a silver lining in our
lap and morin locks the melbourne
shuffle so many more things we could
have done roast chat on the fireplace it
was there that was part of my plan
catch any councillor in a trap complete
the entire mission without using shift
and the two that we completed by boiling
the AJ's face and shocking good old
Mitch okay let's do one more challenge
number three what have you got to offer
the cars to head everyone is missing and
the phone line was cut and now the power
is up this is really starting to freak
me out kid II know it's weird but it's
probably nothing no too many things are
happening for this all to be a
coincidence something feels wrong Chad
must not have topped off the generator
with gas probably token too much of his
weed you rest here I'll go see what's
the matter with the generator so this
one looks to be a little less
complicated than last times two people
in here and he's going to come out suit
yeah there he goes look at that we're
getting used to it now there's a system
to this one always goes out alone and we
would go in and kill the one inside on
this time let's follow Kenny wherever
the hell he's going this is a stock
point yeah there's a house
good old stock points Kenny got you
there he is oh so good that mode I
absolutely love the powers it's so
different this game it deserves more
attention any goals let's watch Kenny's
demise well it's not the gasps someone
turned it off
oh wow just wow
[Music]
yeah peel for mother we shall indeed
make them suffer mama it looks like
though she's already noticed us so this
may not go to plan I don't think we're
going to get away with a decent score
here but we'll still have a little bit
of fun cuz we can stalk through windows
what else could you want in a video game
well let's have a little bit of fun with
her let's put a trap on each of the
doors and we'll see how the AI
approaches the situation another window
to stalks will be there she's still
definitely indoors so we'll pop another
one here she hasn't even locked the door
come on basics of horror films okay
let's see
io in this dough no let's go around
let's go run this year's run away in
fact do you know what I find you
adorable
oh I've loved this game okay so that's
the first three levels done and dusted
the first three challenges of Friday the
13th it's been a whole year since they
said this was coming but it's finally
here so hip hip bloody hooray
I've had so much fun with this if you'd
like to see any more please do me a
favor and just check a comment below I
would love to do more of these it's been
an absolute pleasure thank you so much
for spending this time with me I hope he
don't have nightmares and I'll see you
next time it's been an absolute pleasure
I'm Adam from PlayStation goodnight
[Music]